inside each one of your cells there is
six feet of DNA made up of six billion
letters of genetic code now your DNA is
split into 46 pieces each three to four
centimetres long called chromosomes now
normally we think of chromosomes as
looking like this but they only take
that form when a cell is ready to divide
so usually DNA is just a Wiggly thread
within the nucleus now if you can
imagine DNA is only about two nanometers
wide but a chromosome is centimeters
long so you would think that would get
tangled worse than the headphones in
your bag so the DNA is actually wrapped
around proteins called histones
now those histones have Wiggly tails
which will come in handy as we'll see in
a moment your unique set of DNA first
formed when 23 chromosomes from your mum
mixed with 23 from your dad now 22 of
those chromosomes from each parent form
matching pairs but the 23rd set is the
sex chromosomes so two x chromosomes
make you female and an X and a Y make
you male
now since the male sex chromosomes are
different both can remain active for the
rest of your life but for females one of
the X chromosomes needs to be
inactivated in order for proper
development to occur this happens when a
female embryo is just four days old and
consists of only 100 cells right now in
this cell the X chromosome from dad and
the one from mum are both active but
through a tiny molecular battle one of
the X chromosomes wins and remains
active while the other is inactivated
this is done by packing the DNA closer
together and making modifications to
those dangly histone tails that signal
this inactivation new structural
proteins are also added to bind
everything closer together and finally
methyl groups these tiny little
molecular markers are added to the DNA
to basically signal to the cell that
this DNA shouldn't be read so all of
this together makes the DNA very
difficult to access for the molecular
machinery that would harness the code in
this DNA it is switched off this DNA is
silenced in contrast the active X
chromosome DNA
is more spread out this allows better
access to the genes on the chromosome
histones can be slid along the DNA or
removed entirely and histone tails have
a different modification signaling this
DNA is active now all of this makes it
possible for RNA polymerase to access
and transcribe this DNA into messenger
RNA which then goes out into the cell
and is used to make a protein now what's
surprising about X chromosome
inactivation is that it seems kind of
random which X chromosome wins I mean in
some cells dad's X chromosome wins and
in others mum's X chromosome wins
so this 100 cell embryo ends up with a
mixture of active X chromosomes but from
this point forward as these cells divide
they maintain the active X chromosome
that they had inside so all of the cells
with dads active X chromosome give rise
to further cells with dads active X
chromosome and this continues on into
adulthood so if you could look at a
woman's skin and see which x chromosome
has been inactivated you would see a
stripy pattern which shows the growth
and migration of all of these first
100 cells when the embryo was just four
days old now of course you can't
actually see that in humans but you can
see this with calico cats and that's
because the gene for coat color is
actually on the X chromosome so just by
looking at the pattern of her spots here
her dark and light spots you can see
where her mom or dad's X chromosome has
been inactivated and this also shows us
that only female cats can be calkins and
that's because well only female cats can
inherit two x chromosomes with two
different color genes now this is just
one really cool example of epigenetics
but epigenetics doesn't normally work on
one whole chromosome in fact it's at
play in all of your chromosomes turning
on and off your genes for example it's
epigenetics which makes a pancreatic
cell capable of producing insulin
because that gene is switched on there
but switched off everywhere else what's
more interesting is that it seems the
behaviors you take can actually affect
your epigenetics and even weirder
perhaps the things that your parents or
grandparents did can affect your
epigenetics now can affect your DNA so
you are not just a product of your
genetic code you're not just a product
of your DNA you are also a product of
your epigenetics and that is influenced
by your behavior and the behavior of
your ancestors